[Music]
hi there I'm Andrew Whitaker thanks for
listening before we get into this week's
podcast with a and Katrin Weber I'll
just highlight the final few events
we're hosting the semester and hope you
will join us next Thursday May 3rd we
have the University of Toronto Scott
Richmond talking about the hashtag black
lives matter he describes it
fascinatingly as a networked form of
black annotation how it makes visible
black lives and the violence they're
subjected to we host Kimberly want you
to brown the following Thursday the 10th
Brown is a visiting assistant professor
with MIT Women's and Gender Studies and
our schools in literature section she'll
be presenting her work on US media
coverage particularly photography of
South African apartheid in 1990 and 91
its final year and the images that
anchored viewers interpretation of it I
was a kid then and man the power of the
images of those few years we had you
know fist pumping and pickaxes on top of
the Berlin Wall in 89 the Gulf War was
broadcast live on CNN a year later Red
Square and 91 that tanks just sit there
like props as the Soviet Union ended and
then of course South Africa sitting at
my grandparents house watching TV as the
news cuts in to broadcast Nelson
Mandela's speech as he's released from
prison but Professor Brown will remind
us that the celebration was preceded by
decades of indifference to the black
South African experience and then our
final event of the spring I really hope
you'll join us as our science writing
grad students unveils their theses it's
less a traditional academic presentation
than the reading of some fabulous
long-form features that is Friday May
18th in the MIT Student Center and it
runs all day so come for all of it or
just pop in and out get info on all this
and more at CMS W mit.edu now here's
last night's talk
[Music]
and at least in my research something I
found really intriguing is is how narrow
our imaginary is when it comes to what
television is so how many people would
call surveillance cameras in a grocery
store television or medical intrusive
medical applications in that drugged
state you have to unsavoury going on and
on to the doctor about Wow how amazing
this is live TV like you've never seen
it there are a lot of modalities to
television that we tend not to think of
as the televisual and Anna Catrin Weber
is someone who really does that works in
those spaces are really intriguing ways
we'll hear about some of her research
today in terms of closed-circuit
television she's here thanks to the
Swiss National Science Foundation on a
postdoc doing work on a larger project
that involves drones and imaging through
those systems we've got to know each
other in the course of the dissertation
defense in Lausanne where her
dissertation is a terrific dissertation
really looked at the presentation of
television through through fairs radio
fairs basically and how was this medium
being pitched to a public in 1920s and
30s before it was really accessible and
one of the one of the wonders of
television relative to most of the other
media forms that we work with at least
up until the this latest set of digital
technologies is how pluriform it is how
flexible it is is unlike the book or I'm
like cinema film television is something
that just morphs conceptually it morphs
in terms of how it imagines a
relationship to a make
and user what kinds of inventory evolved
something that we can see for something
like the canvas that moves in
heat-seeking missile technology that
stuff developed into point in the in the
early 1940s basically a form of
television
so anyway her big Anna katrin's work has
really this really looked at these kind
of very complex forms of the televisual
that don't exactly fit with the
mainstream notion of TV that we work
with it's a real pleasure to have you
back thank you thank you thank you very
much thank you Tim for this introduction
thank you I know it's late I tried to be
as interesting as possible and so what
I'm showing you today is indeed part of
a really new research project that
started as a history of televisual uses
and technologies during World War two
and in the meantime it has actually
already become a little bit something
else something larger on televisions
military industrial complex and even
more broadly a research project on CCTV
closed-circuit television systems and as
I would like to discuss during the 45
minutes that I have at this power to do
that is that closed-circuit television
systems constitute a central but largely
overlooked strand of the mediums history
that encompasses most of its development
from the nineteen thirties until today
and that allows to rethink television
within multiple technological social and
political contexts more precisely I wish
to draw a cartography of CCTV uses
throughout the mediums history and this
cartography invites us to explore on the
one hand CCTVs entanglements with
military innovation
and on the other hand to discuss CCTVs
uses in the field of activist media
where closed-circuit systems
his systems are not conceived as app an
app an optic apparatus but form a means
of democratic and horizontal
communication so to start what is CCTV
it's of course a technological system
most basically a camera and a monitor or
a screen that are connected via cable or
today wirelessly and I just I mean you
know all these images I found the CCTV
camera it's supposed to be somewhere in
Cambridge that just streams live 24
hours a day and so this allows me to
illustrate that although CCTV is called
television it has actually little to do
with what we come in commonly you or
define as television that means that
CCTV image quality remains most often
far below the image quality of our TV
set instead of program flow the CCTV
system transmits often static shots from
one particular spot which have little to
no informational value they produce
banal images of what Minnie white has
called a mechanized liveness that is a
liveness that is boring ordinary and
structured by monotonous temporality
what is more standard CCTV systems are
transmitting only visual data in most of
the cases they are mute second obviously
CCTV is also social and the media system
that produces a particular form of
visuality and such particular regimes of
control and power and from the 1990s own
CCTV has indeed become the material
expression of what David Lyon and others
have called the surveillance society
it's almost abacus but
unnoticed presence in our daily spaces
technology technologically sustains too
pervasive monitoring and remote policing
characteristic of societal valence
societies and to quote Clive Norris and
Gary Armstrong the CCTV gaze is
therefore far more than just the
friendly eye in the sky those subject to
the gaze of the cameras cannot challenge
the intrusion into the territories of
the self
they cannot judge the motives of the
observers and nor can they control how
the images will be used as an emblem of
surveillance society's CCTV gear
functions as a visual regime to which
the observed is subjected without his
consent
or even knowing more recently another
media technology has become the center
of new debates on surveillance control
and the militarization of our societies
namely the drone with the rise of drone
strikes in the wake of 9/11 which is now
accompanied by the profusion of draw
drones in civilian contexts the drone
has become as current Caplin rights
among the most mediated new things of
the present in the introduction to the
volume life in the age of drone where a
warfare that capelin has edited today
together with Lisa parks whom you all
know well the authors highlight that
since 2009 us news media have had a
virtual love affair with the drones a
death cult the importance of drones not
only for contemporary warfare but also
for public discourse is taken up by a
vast body of scholarship that approaches
drones from multiple perspectives
highlighting its role in contemporary
surveillance societies imperialist wars
and illegal killings
however by assimilate drones and CCTV
while trying to think them together as I
do right now
since beyond being a media
she CCTV and drones seem not to share
many similarities one system is unarmed
while the other has become a privileged
weapon of contemporary battle CCTVs
mobility is very limited
while drones are also planes and thus
means of transportation I suggest a
comparison in order to have a highlight
there common features and in particular
one fundamental quality both the drone
and CCTV create a network of humans and
machines in which the observer and the
observed are connected in a closed
structure they constitute a human
machine network of visual ities in which
each part is interdependent and
restricted to the system itself
furthermore the long hours of uneventful
observation that drone operators
describe as well as the instantaneous
but soundless views from above very much
resemble the CCTV features mentioned
before and one could argue that the
drone represents a perfect that since
highly mobile potentially lethal and
extremely versatile form of CCTV
absorbed by the drone CCTV becomes thus
a central feature of the contemporary
robotized battlefield and tangle path of
CCTV and the drone are not specific to
current technological developments but
actually go back to the Second World War
at least from a media historical
perspective CCTV and drones share a
common genealogy that ties them to
military innovation in the 1940s as well
as to televisions history before the
mediums emergence as a mass media in the
1950s what I suggest to do in the first
part of my talk is to address this
shared genealogy in order to
contextualize CCTV
systems within the history of military
media I wish to think through and wit
with televisions military-industrial
complex from a historical perspective
which allows to understand the
long-standing entanglement of civilian
and military research in the field of TV
I will discuss CCTV systems by exploring
their fluid transition between military
industrial commercial and policing
contexts starting in the 1940s and going
roughly to the 1970s the second part of
my talk which will be much shorter it's
radical just a kind of outlook of what I
wish doing in the future so the second
part of my talk seeks to complicate
further the historical analysis of CCTV
systems by introducing another context
for which closed-circuit systems were
crucial namely the first activist uses
of small-sized television and video
equipment
if CCTV leads us into the field of
televisions military-industrial complex
CCTV also invites us to look beyond the
surveillance paradigm and to rethink the
flexibility and adaptability of
technological systems within various
political contexts that include leftist
community and art based experiments
organized in the wake of social and
political or protest movements at the
end of the nineteen sixties but so to
begin some broader contextual
information on TVs early history
although I won't really not spend a much
time on that since I think you are
familiar with Williams work so I don't
have to get into the details but just as
a reminder at the outbreak of world war
two television services had opened in
the US and in Europe and the
commercialization of television as a
domestic media had been prepared
prepared in several countries the years
leading to the war does have seen the
launching of what should become the most
and use of television which would define
Mouse most of its media identity up
until today namely the program program
based commercially or public funded
broadcasting into domestic family homes
however the interwar period is
interesting not only for understanding
the origins of institutional frameworks
and domestic technologies but the
interwar period is also fascinating
since it reveals the broad range of
television forms and uses that William
has also mentioned in his introduction
and I I won't need to dwell on this
aspect William has discussed televisions
interpretive flexibility in his work and
has highlighted the many uses of
televisual technologies platforms etc
developed from the 1920s on I just show
you two sources as a reminder so during
the 1920's 1930's television was
imagined for instance as a picture phone
or as a large screen projection device
for settings for cinema like settings
doctors which means collective reception
from the perspective of interwar
televisions highly flexible identity the
first proposal for televisual weapons
appeared to be yet another proof of the
mediums elasticity written in 1934 by
RCA's Radio Corporation of America's
head engineer for television Vladimir
Zworykin and titled
flying to pay the with an electric eye
the proposal envisions a televisual
weapon that closely resembles
contemporary weapon systems since it
embraces remote targeting the visual
data transfer more precisely in his
papers work in projects one major role
for television in the military namely to
transmit an image from the of the target
from the nose of the missile in 1934 f4
and at the same time that Sorkin was
working to
electronic television for domestic use
hurricane was also conceiving a military
apparatus this television system was not
simply an extension or adaptation of the
broadcast media but established actually
a new televisual
dispositive apparatus instead of
conceptualizing television as a program
media transmitting from a central point
to many receivers the core of twerkins
torpedo television was formed by a
communication network in which visual
information circulated between the
target the torpedo and the carrier plane
torpedo can be guided to its target by
shortwave radio control the operator
being able to see the target through the
eye of the torpedo as it approaches the
carrier airplane receives the picture
viewed by the torpedo while remaining at
an altitude beyond artillery range as
captain Chandler underlines in her
discussion of the 1934 paper swara keen
uses mostly the passive voice
she writes interactions that would have
relied on both image and operator were
attributed instead to airplane and
camera in swara Keynes televisual
torpedo the human operators role was
indeed limited the technical system
appeared as almost autonomous this
discursive unmanned name of weapons and
more broadly the arming of technological
systems represent of course a paradox
insofar as the human intervention is
obviously central to the system it
however underscores the in imaginary of
closed circuit systems thought of as
shield networks within which the
different components form an
interconnected but independent structure
from which humans are excluded
while Sorkin's ideas that he put to
paper in 34 did not find immediate
application televisual research for the
army anti ray Navy actually became an
important field of technological
innovation at RCA especially after the
Pearl Harbor attack in 41 and the
subsequent intensified war effort at RCA
various research projects were put to
put together and research into
televisual military equipment became an
important activity for the cooperation
during World War two I won't enter into
the details of this research but I'd
like to highlight two observations first
is that military television developed in
different directions so in addition to
telling itíd missiles such as described
by its work in television was also
employed in so-called target target
drones these are drones for training
uses or as an instrument for
reconnaissance reconnaissance all these
applications were based on a conception
of television as closed-circuit
transferring visual information from the
camera to one single receiver second a
shared characteristic of all these
different systems was the reduction of
size and weight of the different
components that form the television
systems as well as a simplification of
use and maintenance as David Sarnoff
arcee's president a president summed up
in September 1946 so that's a an issue
of RCA's review that was published just
just after the war that presented some
of our CIA's
wartime work so Sarnoff writes three air
porn television systems the block Turing
and the MIMO evolved for secret wartime
purposes television pick up and
transmitting equipment that once might
have filled a large room was redesigned
modified and built to suitcase
compactness for military uses
the importance of small size and
lightweight technologies while Sarnoff
was of course very positive about his
company's achievements during the war
the airborne television systems were
actually not extremely successful from a
military point of view Catherine
Chandler and others interpret these
experiments indeed as a failure insofar
as the unmanned weapon systems were of
only buried it limited use during World
War two and their missions were mostly
limited to test flights and experimental
runs in this sense
toric in the vision of a televised
television weapon did not come to
realize however the extended
applicability of television beyond the
media of broadcasting the imaginary of
unmanned as well as the televisual
operation in the field of targeting
surveillance and control would have a
long lasting impact on CCTV uses well
beyond the war and that's why I suggest
to move to the post-war context and to
have a look at CCTV during the 50s and
70s in order to argue that the
technological innovation that was pushed
forward with regard to drones and
missiles was not lost after World War
two but was actually reattached to the
new post-war context in other words
thinking of drones not only as a
military instrument but as part of the
broader history of CCTV brings me to
explore continuities of technological
innovation and social imagination
between the war and the post-war years
these continuities highlight does tell
it that television during world war ii
was not so much a failure than a project
that gave birth to multiple uses of TV
within as well as beyond the military
framework
televisions that is most often focus on
the post-war years as the as the moment
when the medium emerges as a
domesticated mass media Lynne beagles
work for instance which I hope you all
know has shown us how television was
shaped but also contested as a family
apparatus that rearranged domestic
spaces as well as domestic relations
this body of historical scholarship
influenced by cultural studies and
feminist approaches in particular is
central to understand the making of TV
as the new mass media from the 1950s on
however focusing on the domestic
framework television historiography has
a tendency to overlook alternative
televisual uses and practices so the
first point I would like to make here is
to honor these continuity's between war
and post-war research and to discuss
those forms of televisual applications
that are in my understanding direct
inheritors of military based
developments in spring 1960 46 or in
1946 so after the war the RCA laboratory
news a company internal magazine for
employees included an article on
airborne television revealing some of
the secret wartime research while the
article honors RCA's accomplishments
during the war and lists the different
quote wartime uses of the television
system it also looks beyond military
development and discusses possible
civilian applications of these
television systems the editor forecasts
widespread applications in industry with
adaptations destined to become eyes in
factories and large-scale production
enterprises and the means of watching
and controlling from a distance
manufacturing processes and situations
that might otherwise be an
inaccessible or too perilous to man so
these are the potential uses of his
wartime televisual research according to
the RCA laboratory news this transfer
from the military to the civilian
context of new television technologies
he projected by the in-house editor was
realized during the 1950's when a new
field of television applications become
became the new commercial playground for
non broadcasting TV this new field of
television was promoted under the label
of industrial television industrial
television was based on reduced size and
limited quality television equipment and
built as closed-circuit systems
indeed for numerous authors who turned
to industrial TV explaining its workings
and benefits the notion of
closed-circuit television became not
only central but actually a defining a
concept to describe the specificities of
industrial TV this means that at this
moment in the mid 50s the notion itself
became for the first time a household
name that circulated in professional
literature the press and Beyond and here
a quote from fifty-six closed circus
circuit television involving
transmission directly to one or more
special audiences rather than to the
public is steadily increasing in news
the reasons for its quick and widespread
adaptation are simple ease of operation
labor and time saving economies it may
it may be expected to be a basic tool of
an ever-increasing number of commercial
industrial educational and governmental
operations of the future from the
mid-1950s the applications for CCTV
indeed almost universal disgust
internationally and constituting a
transnational phenomenon to industrial
TV vas ought to encompass a wide range
of potential uses and I just show you a
few sources that illustrate these uses
that were implemented or at least
projected so the first one is at a
factory the idea of when we identified
Eve Arif ocation then you have on the
left
CCTV within the bank switch to control
the checking balance etc and also there
is I think there is a drive-in counter
that uses CCTV on the right it's CCTV in
educational settings which was a big
part of industrial TV for the
universities to broadcast the lecture to
several rooms and here this wonderful
overview of all the uses and fields
where industrial to you is actually
thought to be useful though so it goes
from advertisement to woolen mills and
then includes prisons of course police
stations of whatever shops libraries etc
etc so it's basically CCTV s for each
and every branch of our contemporary
modern industry
so my point is to underline that during
the post-war years a new form of closed
circuit systems merged that was linked
to televisual research during World War
two
but also distinct from Tel Aviv from the
televisual torpedo that it's working had
imagined insofar as it in integrated
civilian spaces rather than military
research and in order to tease out a
little bit the meanings of this shift
from the military through the factory to
the schools through the public spaces
more broadly I would like to turn to a
case study that is taken from the city
where I currently live which is Lausanne
in Switzerland and so this is a case
study about or a story rather about
traffic surveillance in the early 60s
Lausanne in the early sixties was around
the 4th largest city in Switzerland so
it was rather an important city with
around 120,000 inhabitants which is not
a lot of course compared to US cities
but still what is actually really
important is that in 64 the National
Fair was held in Lausanne and so for one
season from April to October Lawson
became the center of Switzerland with a
total of over 12 million visitors
converging on the fairgrounds and this
prospect of massive visitor flows was
accompanied in the city Parliament by a
debate on traffic control in the city
center that had already started in the
1950s so before actually the planning of
the fair had started the discussion held
in the city Parliament evolved around
the necessity to reform the current
traffic organization in order to
anticipate the growth of private cars
and thus traffic volume which would even
increase during the National Exhibition
of course
the solution chosen to solve the problem
of traffic jams and traffic flows and to
render traffic fluid that was the most
important actually aspect of the whole
debate was of technological nature it
was called licinia disease only news
automatic or automated light signaling
which is basically doesn't what you all
know as a synchronization of several
light traffic lights over multiple
intersections allowing drivers to drive
through the intersections without having
to stop at a red light and this
automated light control was promoted
under the label Korean Wave was promoted
the label Green Wave Saria the complete
automatization that's the problem that's
where TV comes in in the story the
complete automatisation of synchronized
green lights however was not possible
during peak hours in particular the
system needed to be readjusted with
regard to the different intensities of
traffic flows which were actually really
hard to predict to keep the traffic
fluid and the cars on the go it was
necessary to keep an eye on the entire
trajectory in the city centre and I that
was of course provided by industrial
television so each traffic light in the
city centre was equipped with the
television camera monitoring the
intersections and the traffic flow and
that's just to give you an idea of what
it might look like the camera was linked
by cable to the control room set at a
pole set up at the police headquarters
from which one traffic officer could
oversee the entire traffic flow and
adjust traffic lights at the distance if
necessary and so what's interesting is
that here you see this control room a
picture from 69 in 64 when the system
lounge there were actually only nine
cameras so nine cameras and us nine
screens in 69 there are already 16 so
it's also a system that is expanding and
more and more cameras are actually set
up in the city centre as one
enthusiastic defender of the television
system explained televisual observation
complements the signaling the traffic
control room can intervene at any moment
everywhere it is no longer a succession
of blind machines it is a circulation
regulated by an intelligence that
understands all the elements of the
problem and provides immediate and
efficient solutions thanks to the
television equipment us the entire
system could now be regulated as a whole
thanks to television a henceforth blind
network would become intelligent that
that's at least the argument of the
speaker
what is again striking in this quote is
obviously this discursive on Manning of
the television technology regulated not
by a police officer but by a control
room this unmanned iing again is at the
origin of the system's efficiency and
intelligence epitomized in the idea of
the control room an entirely
technological space and is reflected by
other sources from the same period such
as here the photograph of another
traffic control room from the u.s. in 62
yet again of course as with the
televisual weapons the unmanned
obviously represents a paradox since the
police officer was literally at the core
of the system the data transmission and
image loops provided I Industrial TV
required adjustment and control which
were executed by the officer in other
words and to use the cybernetic
vocabulary of the 1960's the televisual
system continuously triggered feedback
that asked for human intervention so in
Lausanne Industrial TV was first used
for traffic control it was by the way
the first city in Switzerland that
actually implemented such a traffic
control system with industrial TV from
the very early debates on however the
television system was also part of the
national first security design and
that's why I've talked about the
national fair at the beginning of course
for the occasion
six additional cameras were acquired to
oversee the different parking lots
around the fair but also of course to
oversee the exhibition grounds itself
and in particular the visitors again the
control room was set up at the fair for
immediate observation and that allowed
for immediate observation through a
rapid intervention and this example of
the fair also highlights what has been
said or what has been left unsaid rather
until now namely that industrial
television may provide efficient
solutions to traffic or urban planning
problems it always also potentially
functions as a tool of surveillance and
an instrument of public control as one
left-wing politician would underline
during a heated debate in their Lausanne
city Parliament in 1966 the telephoto
lenses that are part of the camera so
you can zoom of course you can move the
camera pan and you consume the telephoto
lenses allow a la bit like the wire tape
to recognize distinctly anyone in the
field of the cameras and that he had
some reason some actual reason to
express his concerns is confirmed by
this surveillance footage that is that
was shot and edited by the police
Lausanne police during youth protests in
1918 1981
where they used the traffic control the
traffic cameras to actually of course
tape the protesters it's also the video
quality that so it's edited tape that
really documents the whole protest march
and you can imagine that it is actually
possible really possible to recognize
the people since of course probably know
most of the protesters present so to
conclude this first part the televisual
application subsumed under the label
industrial television did not represent
a break with military developments but
rather extended into new contexts some
of the technological and epistemological
fundaments of military military
television as this french advertisement
summarizes industrial television is to
answer to two requirements to develop
productivity and individual gain and to
replace man by a machine at least as
intelligent as himself in other words
industrial television shifted the
epidemiological framework to think about
television from military reconnaissance
and targeting towards control efficiency
and governance without however excluding
civilian surveillance or remote policing
what is more the idea of unmeaning
industrial policing or other processes
remained at the core of its definition
thus instead of thinking as world war ii
television as a failure it seems
important to better understand the
entangled history of military and
civilian technologies for at least two
reasons first as high davison has argued
in her new volume on cinemas
military-industrial complex the military
in her case the US Army Navy has been a
prolific media producer and distributor
whose institutional imperatives have
co-constructed cinematic forms and
practices that continued after the war
while some survey of military viewing
protocols brings to the light the
elasticity and malleable malleability of
cinema outside the traditional framework
of its consumption namely the movie
theater with regard to the history of
television we cannot stress enough the
multiplicity of televisual forms and
uses that were projected and developed
from the 1920s on the military
industrial framework represents a
central space within which alternative
media identities are defined second to
think about televisions military
industrial context from a historical
perspective invites us to question
boundaries between civilian spaces and
the battlefield and in particular to
better understand their porosity in a
long-term perspective in her piece on
the contemporary what she calls drone
arama Karen Kaplan highlights the fluid
movement between military and civilian
populations and machinery which troubles
the supposed firm line between these
sectors of society the history of CCTV
is it seems particularly well-suited to
stress the fluidity between military and
commercial developments and to
underscore the porosity of military and
civilian spheres
so for the second part of my talk which
will be really short so don't worry
I'd like to broaden the cartography of
CCTV beyond this military-industrial
complex and argue that CCTV is rebel
relevant beyond the question of
surveillance and policing to understand
televisions multifaceted identity to do
so I first introduced you to a short
example that is taken from my PhD that
William has mentioned in the
introduction when I came across for the
first time when I came for the first
time across CCTV systems although I did
not think of them as CCTV systems I will
show you an example in a second and then
and this will be really definitely the
last part I will move to the 1970s
activist experiments using television in
community settings that I suggest we can
also understand as a closed-circuit
system so the first argument I would
like to make is that the history of CCTV
actually does not start with military
innovation or industrial TV but is part
of televisions early history in the
twenties and thirties when
closed-circuit systems were actually the
norm for many demonstrations and public
displays in order to render visible
televisions capacity for transmitting at
a distance the public had to be able to
observe at once the moment of
transmission and reception for
television demonstrations the best way
to prove the mediums potential for a
nearly a annihilating space by time was
by approaching transmitter and receiver
and create a closed-circuit system in
order to demonstrate seeing at a
distance which is like the basic
definition of television the distance
was literally made graspable for
visitors and
show you two examples one from 37a
Telefunken chairman big important
chairman today mission development
developer who presented red cross
spilled shame you've traveled sound like
I saw and speak your large screen
transmission apparatus just a literal
translation a device that allowed for an
instantaneous transmission of a
speaker's voice and image which was rare
projected to a large screen play it
plays behind the person and so you have
like the the outline on the left and
then a picture of the actual
demonstration on the right and you see
that so the the camera is in front of
the person who speaks and then behind
this is his image the speaker's body
located in between the camera and the
screen constituted to acts around which
the system as a whole was organized the
apparatus was self-sufficient and
self-contained the televisual space
covered few meters between the camera
the projection and the speaker's eye
representation and reception as well as
representation and reality collapsed
temporally and spatially creating an
audio-visual loop in which television
exhibited itself and another telling
example of such an audio-visual each
loop constitutes this other exhibition
studio that was also put up at the
Berlin radio fair but one year earlier
in 36 and where you have the production
space behind the glass behind the
windows and in front you have the
receiving set so that visitors can
observe at the same time the making of
television and the actual television
image so these two examples show that
during here during the mediums
experimental phase in the 20 in 20s and
30s when television was introduced to
the broader public closed-circuit
systems were instrumental for the public
demonstration
of televisions potentialities and
participated in defining the medium part
of its public display the closed circuit
design was exhibited even celebrated
rather than hidden from sight as it
would be the case 50 years later with
CCTV in public space yet another role
was played by CCTV in the 1970s when
different initiatives of community-based
television emerged internationally from
the light 60s and early 70s owned a new
idea about television was discussed
partly linked to the introduction of
lighter and cheaper video equipment the
porta pack partly also due to the
broader social and political context of
course of protest movement in the wake
of may 68 summarised under the label
guerrilla TV or community television a
diverse array of television experiments
sought to oppose the commercial system
in the US and the monolithic public
services in Europe by creating networks
of television dialogue tied to media art
and leftist activist initiatives these
experiments shared a willingness to undo
what had become a common feature of
mainstream TV namely the one directional
form of televisual non communication in
the sense that broadcast television only
transmits in one direction and does not
allow for a feedback for actual feedback
so these guerrilla TV or community
television experiments critiqued
monopolistic tendencies and commercial
influences as well as the difficult even
impossible access to the oil waves for
most of televisions audiences instead of
exclusion they sought to create
inclusionary plaque practices and the
well known experiment of activist
television was the video freaks pirate
TV station
erected in Lanesville New York which was
called
Plainsville TV and in operation between
72 and 77 transmitting from a farm via a
self built antenna to the inhabitants of
the small town the people from lanes
will were regularly invited to
participate in the broadcast the video
freaks team furthermore repeated the
station's phone number on air so that
the community could call in and interact
with the live broadcast and I'll show
you just a very brief excerpt of this
kind of lightweight low technology
broadcast that also puts forward a very
intimate tone that is central to the
understanding of what this community TV
should look like
TV that for two people by the people
that addresses the community that goes
that works directly with the lanes will
habitants this ideal of community
television is of course no longer a
closed-circuit system in the strictest
sense insofar as it transmits to all
inhabitants of the locality but it
creates I argue I would you argue a
community through television and
functions thus as some how autonomous
media cosmos within the context of lanes
slow TV and other experiments
broadcasting did not signify the sending
of a program flow to the broadest
possible audience but rather to create a
democratic even intimate media
environment by transmitting locally
anchored and locally produced content
community or a guerrilla TV I would like
does argue can be understood as yet
another form of closed-circuit systems
within which the closed structure is not
subjected to paradigms of control and
surveillance but to exchange
communication and dialogue while
certainly including a broader network of
receivers than the traffic control
system or the world war two drones
presented before the ideal of
small-scale and activist television also
seeks to create a restricted televisual
space a restriction however that is not
in the service of an optic apparatus or
the military industrial complex instead
of the vertical mediation brought about
by drones which Lisa parks among others
describes in her work community circle
explore the possibility of a horizontal
mediation in which machinery and humans
construct new forms of communication
maybe most tellingly for this shift from
vertical to horizontal from surveillance
to democratic exchange is the fact that
in most illustrations that accompanies
with your freaks and other collectives
work the human is not evacuated but
rather put into the center and that's a
drawing from 71 so from one of the
projects that with your freaks had
actually before launching lanes will TV
but you see that it is this idea of a
closed circuit system where two people
are actually at the center looking at
the TV monitors and being able also to
intervene with the camera so that's like
my final final thought I would like to
go back through the introduction and
highlight that why I have started with
the definition of what CCTV is it
appears now after having outlined CCTVs
history from the 30s to the 70s that its
characteristics are actually far from
being stable CCTV does not constitute a
fixed media form but can help us to
think through and with various
technological technologies and practices
shifting from military to civilian
contexts from governance to activists
initiatives CCTV as a particular form of
televisual t adapt to multiple contexts
beyond the surveillance paradigm as such
it opens new strands of television
history that help understand the mediums
meaning outside its mainstream
institutions thank you
[Music]
if I understand it it's basically a
question about the function of cinema
within this broader military industrial
complex or I mean there are there are
several of course it's always it is a
way of familiarizing us with these
images and but also of rendering that
those image is very ordinary since we
see them as part of a cinematographic
narrative at the same time and I was one
I wanted first to show an excerpt of
eyes in the sky which works with drones
I mean there is also often these
narratives are actually really helpful
to think about technologies become or or
or the problems they potentially pose
because they put again in the center to
human contrary to what I've shown of
course then that there is the question
of ethics that is that it's put forward
etc so the movies also at least some of
them try to
[Music]
or help us to think in another way
contrary to these technological systems
where all the humans are really excluded
you know we're talking about the
military industry to some of these
technologies were the kinds of ways of
seeing that were desired in those views
and then you sort of juxtaposing back to
things like things for TV and interested
in how the degrees to which we have
learned to desire to see you into these
machines and the degree to which these
kinds of alternative forms might have
pursued a different aesthetics I'm
thinking about James Scottsboro can seem
like a state but also recently I'm also
thinking about so people are playing
around with drugs Android visuals
there's one cheeky video called rum
foaming which is basically TRO made
pornography made by photography
directors so they're essentially
shooting at people having sex in all
sorts of random places from looking
there is a view of a drone which I think
brings to life this kind of weird way in
which the bird's-eye view or the
elevator view has become really familiar
to us a very ordinary but it's also we
were made to desire this kind of very
clean and beautiful quote unquote
whereas I would enter inside view I'm
just curious about whether these
alternative points pursue just one of
the clips or whether they pursue for you
a different possibility on what kind of
vision remainder design yeah definitely
I mean that's I think that this work is
shift from vertical two and two
horizontal can actually be helpful to
think through because these community
television experiments try to create a
non-hierarchical system is basically the
person who watches TV is also the person
who makes TV I mean
just as a side note of course what I
have lied out kind of ideal form of
community TV actually in the 70s a lot
of these experiments take not really
work out a dwell or we're also absorbed
by commercial imparative so the really
me community media based access is
always a little bit complicated to
create but at least as an ideal form of
communication it is about creating an
image that is non-structured higher
hierarchy and that is that can be
appropriated by everybody whereas of
course drone and the views from above
images always create vertical and
already structured hierarchical
hierarchy between structured view or a
gaze certainly one of the ways of
thinking about the genesis of
televisions could think about images
sent through telephone lines and
certainly late 19th century those are
effectively think about that I think
really makes interesting use of
closed-circuit actually coming from
sound sounds work and that's the work of
Pyke and that fluxes people working with
the tone to the video art which is
usually
no I mean that's I haven't touched upon
media art as such because it opens a
completely other field that is already
very reversed but that's true of course
early video experiments undo the
broadcasting the idea of broadcasting by
creating these closed-circuit systems
that's one thing and the other that I
would add to another form also of
creating community through
closed-circuit systems was actually the
videotape libraries or databases they
with your freaks and others created
where they had they made their own
videotapes that they they were sent
around and basically so that's also
audio-visual content that is traveling
in the flow sphere among friends and
video activists etc so that's also yet
and and where the support like the
material device is a video tape yeah
yeah so I think there it is I mean
that's I mean that's for sure like from
the 19th century the telephone was the
first reference for creating this
imaginary of ubiquitous etcetera and and
then yes I think the idea of this
alternative general genealogy that
something I'm trying to figure out now
how to think about all these different
[Music]
examples and historical moments that we
wouldn't necessarily subsume under the
label of CCTV but that actually produce
distill the visuality of closed
world or something that is not open not
it's not broadcast in this literal sense
but it's really something else and I
think you're right there is there are a
lot of actually other media forms that
would also that would also allow to
create other historical narratives from
television and into my other mid
intermedia links
television with other media
so which no that's that's a great
question because I started working on
community television while looking at a
community-based TV station again in Los
Angeles so which was founded in the
early 2000 and which was first only big
cable so it was it's like what would you
call it one of these big building
neighborhoods for with low rent
apartments and as a social project they
wanted to bring in community-based
television so there was one spot on the
cable that was reserved for this
television station and of course then
with the internet at some point rapidly
these programs got also put on the
internet and the word us made access
accessible to everyone and it's actually
basically it's the same with this
example here too suddenly we can see
what was actually planned to be seen
only par by the really local people and
it po it poses a question of how to
interpret these images that are not
directly addressed at us they these
images are not made for us but they are
made for a particular community within
which all these people they know each
other so in the case of this Lausanne TV
station there is a lot of there are a
lot of different languages that are
spoken on on-air it's often it's very
amateurish it's a rather boring program
quote-unquote etc so how do what do you
do then with this
[ __ ] that are because of internet
circulating on the World Wide Web but
which are actually really at the at the
basis salt for a very limited public or
a limited audience and that's something
I think we have to take into
consideration when we talk about this
kind of videos and especially about
community TV we cannot judge these
broadcast in terms of anesthetic in the
sense of so boring would actually be
really a bad objective to talk about it
because it's not about whether it's
interesting or not interesting it's it's
about something else it's creating a
link talking about the name so yeah
Internet is really interesting for that
because it's so how much do you think of
the imaginary is kind of constructed
within corporate culture are see any in
this case is a generator not just of the
technologies they're patented but even
notions of application did you see that
is directional is that sort of informing
how the telephone about to what level
twenty spent in these these shared
licences goodness
healthy constructor shape transnational
imaginary well that's a good question
I mean what I first thing I would like
to say is that I have I have done some
some archives to RCA archives at Hagley
library and it's always with with
regards to military development during
World War Two there is absolutely no
reference to any foreign development at
all it's really RCA I mean what what we
have the records we have in the US
archives are always kind of blending out
there so that's one thing and then I I
don't think that the image imaginary is
only I mean it's definitely a
transnational one and I'm I wouldn't say
it's only shaped by the corporate
culture it's of course broader so but it
I and that was part of my project was
but I'm not sure whether it's really
doable but part of my project was to
look at which components which engineers
worked on which components which camera
tubes or whatever and what would they
say about these but like really the
materiality of of these systems and
whether and I think that would be a way
maybe to understand how they really in
detail how they conceptualized different
forms of television but yeah other than
that I'm not sure I can't really answer
that question I think it's yeah it's a
tricky issue there's a lot of RCA
correspondents in Germany of our state
writing to the to the post ministry
when you go to the RCA yeah
and we were talking earlier there's a
lot of interrogations to take place
right after the war where basically
American television engineers are
interrogating their German counterparts
and it's like we do need to hold buddies
Fritz I haven't seen you in three years
like how did you guys solve this problem
in that problem and one of the most
moving things is a demonstration of a
guidance system in the rocket so
effectively the system where the target
is a photo over the crawl space and
they're located all these engineers are
University a German and whatever they're
looking at this guidance system through
this tunnel a really large rocket and
they're kind of targeting on this base
like so people with your immediate
extremis but I mean when shooting this
girl's face that's that's another thing
but what has always struck me already
during my PhD is that often the pictures
that even for so in the 2030s they have
to illustrate whatever television
picture would look like look like when
you take a certain number of lines so
like a high resolution versus
lower-level resolution television
pictures and to illustrate the questions
they're very technical question of how
many pixels and how many lines etc they
often take women and often
women's body so it's really about like
and this is so I am not sure whether
that's corporate culture or a scientific
culture or a patriarchal culture or just
everything together but it's definitely
like a transnational until not only
imaginary in this case a true and
transnational practice to often use
women's faces and women overall to
illustrate very technical details which
means that they will of course never
comment upon
the woman that we see in the picture
they always will comment upon the
picture frame and the number of lines
etc so that's but that's like a good
example of how actually in Germany in
the u.s. in France it's these examples
are definitely transnational public
faces under this land demonstration
shocks along with the cabinet designs
domesticate the technology actually for
hobbyists to a certain extent but then
it's also I I've seen so many of these
pictures in very technical magazines so
that's not something that is really for
engineers and professionals so it's not
[Music]